hey hey hey hallo mein name ist herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von milch bei twitter gesagt wir
sollten wir mal videos einsenden wie ihr
auf ein video von mir reagiert und
darauf reagiere ich dann jetzt
[Musik]
ich glaube so geht s tatsächlich jedem
meiner zuschauer wenn sie sich ein video
von mir anschauen hat jetzt zwar nichts
mit einem video von mir zu tun ob das du
reagiert hast aber es tut mir sehr leid
das den teller zu klein ist für meine
pizza ich in köln habe nicht das problem
in meinem fach dass die pizza da nicht
rein passt aber meine mutter beschwert
sich auch immer dass die pizza zu groß
ist für unsere tiefkühl etwas milder
[Musik]
warum schickst du mir so einen video so
lobe ich mir dass freunde das war ganz
richtig wie im film so mit dem rand
schnitzen und zu zeigen und so aber hey
leute warum ruft ihr das denn jetzt
schon die neue kollektion kommt doch
erst eine acht tagen
erster 12.15 uhr luca meedia.de fünf
neue produkte warten auf euch ja wir
machen weiter welches der beste job der
welt genau so redet ein pikachu ja
wirklich genauso ich soll auf einem
video von ihr energien ja genau das soll
zu machen weil das habe ich gesagt das
habe ich gebetet und darum soll das
heutige video handeln
danke für dein dehoga das ist hier nicht
gut wenn das hier nicht die
luca dürfte nur die lu kapitza essen
genau das sollte man wirklich mit
blutprodukten machen deswegen nehme ich
jetzt hier auch meine bienen wird wieso
habe ich eigentlich bin
hey hey man schon wieder rote kreise und
ein blau siegertyp und jetzt spring
barre werbung
nein tut mir leid dass da jetzt ein
kreislauf den partnern ist und tut mir
leid dass visos haare blau sind und dass
da immer das spring bahre werbung ich
finde youtuber und das machen youtuber
[Musik]
also um es mal ganz kurz
zusammenzufassen sie geht in eine bar
ein
geht nach links und dann auf einmal
sitzen dort diese leute werde
beziehungsweise pferde verkleideten
menschen in der bahn komplett komplett
normaler tag eigentlich wichtiger eine
flasche gegen schrank werfen dass das
kann definitiv nicht das nein warum
fehlt mir sowas zugesendet
[Musik]
natürlich freunde da gucke ich mir hier
das nächste video an indem ich einfach
als dikmen dargestellt werden und
einfach getötet werde
ja schön so was zu sehen was ich finds
mégane ist dass ich voll häufig
einsendungen bekommen wo leute einfach
so kam in schwung.de schreien wenn das
allerdings so ausartet dann mache ich
mir da tatsächlich sorgen um die
gesundheit
mensch du das war ja gar nicht voraus
woanders salei kommt hh hilfe uhren sohn
des wenn ihr noch kein abonnent und
summe doch kein teil der lose seit meine
damen und herren dann drückt einfach
unter dem video auf abonnieren und werde
teil der look you oder hasst es einfach
ich sein video aufnehmen für ist ein
video an der stelle möchte ich mich ganz
recht herzlich bei dir bedanken für
diese einsendung hat mir wirklich jetzt
gerade den tag regelrecht versüßt reicht
dann auch danke dass du so toll auf
meinem video reagiert hast ganz ehrlich
das recht schon mir nicht dienst meinen
hier sind das denke ich mir auch jedes
mal also immer wenn ich meinen eigenen
kanal besucher
sehe ich dieses mal hier also meinen
profilbild und denke so wie ich jetzt
mal schnell wieder weg von der seite das
ist ihr vom video meine damen und herren
ich wollte einfach mal auf ein paar
videos reagieren wie ihr auf meine
videos reagiert das hat allerdings jetzt
diesmal nicht so ganz geklappt wenn in
der nächsten folge luca reagiert dabei
sein wollt erfolg mir gern auf twitter
ihr könnt mir auch gerne bei instagram
snapshot folgen allerdings dazu findet
ihr unten in der video beschreibung ich
bekomme auch die frage gestellt wo kann
mit welcher kamera nimmst du deine
videos auf dies auch immer in der
beschreibung verlinkt sonst will ich
jetzt sagen meine damen und herren heute
ist der 23 november am ersten zwölfter
lounge in lucka shop fünf neue artikel
ein t shirt 2 sweater einen rudi und
socken das heißt am 11 12 10 15 uhr
solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen
tut mir leid dass ich mich war doch so
ein bisschen erkältet anhöre das liegt
daran dass sich erkältet bin ist ein
dummkopf
ja ja dass das wars vom video klares
wasser ziel von bio das war es jetzt
hier vom video hier können jetzt hier
mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier unten
meinen job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die winde nach
richtungen
[Musik]